life in the freezer has always been
perilous but climate change is a new
threat for the animals of Antarctica
some Adelie penguin populations have
halved as temperatures rise their future
is uncertain we drove up onto the
melting ice in an aging snowcat Mike
Bryan runs rather a British Antarctic
Survey 'he's biggest research base
scientists have been monitoring the area
for several decades the coastline to the
left and to the right here and that's a
very clear picture
like the ice coast is melting by on an
annual basis but to the right of us
there are areas where it's melted by
more than a kilometer in the last 30
years
as their place is going to be double bar
Antarctica's ice sheet is up to three
miles deep and so immense that it
contains more than two-thirds of all the
fresh water on the planet the frozen
continent has been slow to respond to
global warming but now it's catching up
Antarctica has lost three trillion tons
of ice over the last twenty-five years
half of that has been in the last five
but it's what could happen next that
really alarmed scientists about four
seasons worth but Joanne Johnson is just
back from sweets Gracia an expanse of
ice the size of Britain that many fear
is about to undergo a catastrophic melt
I've been coming here since 2002 a long
time the whole of the West Antarctic ice
shelf could follow a region so vast that
it would add more than three metres to
global sea levels from her remote camp
she could see the ice beginning to
crumble it looks to me really unstable
and there was a massive crack not that
far from the ice shelf front and that
looks like it's just about to carve off
and it's a huge part of the glass here
and to see that in front of me really
made me think gosh you know this is
happening and I think that I've never
really quite appreciated that in the
same way before scientists don't know
what impact the changing climate will
have a non tart occurs marine mammals
from elephant seals to whales they're
part of a food chain that ultimately
depends on shrimp like krill but the
tiny creatures need ice to survive and
they're having to migrate ever further
towards the pole to find it if their
food supply moves the way then they will
follow that food supply yeah and if
their food supply relies on krill
mackerel disappears so that's why it's
really important to understand those
links through the food chain through the
ecosystem who eats who how much they
rely on that so that then we can start
to predict the impacts on species Louis
so much of the concern about global
warming has been about ice melt on
Greenland but Antarctica is a far bigger
threat the scientists are only just
beginning to understand Thomas More Sky
News in bravura Antarctica